on february 6 2012 chinese police
surrounded the us consulate in chengdu
china in a tense 30-hour standoff
inside huang li-joon frantically pled
for asylum as he presented evidence of
what would become the nation's biggest
scandal in decades
as police chief of the country's third
largest city wong possessed documents he
said which could bring down his boss and
one of the most powerful men in china
boshilai
it all revolved around a british
businessman named neil haywood
in exchange for getting bo's son into a
prestigious boarding school heywood was
rewarded with political favors
but for reasons that are still unclear
beau's wife grew frustrated and
eventually poisoned the man
dramatic oscar-worthy stories like this
one are a dime a dozen in china
in 2019 for example this video
circulated on social media showing 13
and a half tons of gold hidden in a
party secretary's home
between 2012 and 17 alone 1.5 million
officials were disciplined for
corruption that's nearly 700 criminal
charges demotions and dismissals every
single day for six straight years
it should be no surprise then that china
has quote serious corruption problems
according to transparency international
but here's what is surprising
take each country and place it on a line
from most to least corrupt
now on the x-axis show its economic
growth
what emerges is the general trend you'd
expect the less corruption the stronger
an economy
corruption after all is a tax on
business
it scares away investors and diverts
limited resources towards unproductive
roads to nowhere
and yet china is way over here with both
extremely high growth and corruption
how is that possible
how has china defied predictions of
imminent economic collapse every single
year for decades
not by eliminating corruption but by
doing what no other country has managed
to do so effectively
weaponizing it
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch my brand new nebula
original series
this first full-length episode is about
how chinese censorship actually works
and why the regime does sometimes
tolerate dissent
watch it with the curiosity stream and
nebula bundle right now 42 off for
mother's day just 12 bucks a year
if you enjoy these videos sign up to get
50 percent more of them starting today
on the very first day of finance 101
students are taught about the principal
agent problem
capitalism it goes is all about
specialization it isn't efficient or
even possible for each of us to sow our
own clothes solder our own electronics
and be our own doctors
so we outsource each of these jobs to
someone more qualified
modern life in other words requires
delegation
but how do a company's shareholders
ensure its managers who they delegate
decision making to don't misuse their
money
replace shareholders with voters and
managers with politicians and you
understand why eliminating corruption is
a really hard problem
that's in a democracy but even the most
iron fisted dictator can't possibly make
much less implement every last decision
on their own
they too must delegate
say you're the leader of china
whether or not you have the people's
best interest in mind you also know your
legitimacy and therefore your power
depends on some level of competence
while nationalism and censorship afford
the communist party plenty of room for
failure at the end of the day your
continued rule requires food on the
table gas in the tank and at least some
occasional clean water
on a purely organizational level take a
second to appreciate just how hard a
coordination problem it is to convert
words at the top into the actions 99
layers below which result in more high
speed rail than every other country put
together and maintain 10 percent gdp
growth for years on end
now for the sake of simplicity let's
condense those hypothetical 99 layers
into just three
at the very top of the pyramid are a
tiny number of elite party officials
getting them to follow orders is
relatively easy their next promotion
depends on it
the problem lies between them and the
public
the ground-level civil servants who on
any given day actually deliver the
functions of government
providing health care delivering
education and building infrastructure
unlike the elites these officials are
usually stationed in one city for their
entire careers
they aren't playing some house of cards
game of political intrigue they're just
looking to put food on the table and hey
if they can convert what authority they
have into a new car or apartment even
better
and therein lies the problem
the chinese bureaucracy is huge we're
talking 50 million party state employees
aka all of south korea or texas and new
york put together
that's excluding its military the
world's largest and state-owned
enterprises which comprise nine of the
country's 10 largest employers
plus that number is from 2007.
meanwhile thanks to outdated rules and
widespread evasion only 2 percent of the
population paid any income tax in 2015
according to one former official
in other words there just isn't enough
revenue to go around public servants are
paid peanuts
the average nationwide monthly wage is
1298 us dollars
yet the highest paid civil servants make
just 824
and the lowest a measly 80.
this is a dangerous combination lots of
local political power yet thanks to
desperation every incentive to hinder
and steal rather than help the country
how do you convince these local
officials who may not even make a living
wage to stop harassing businesses which
you the leader need to create the jobs
and drive the economic growth that keeps
you in power countries unable to answer
this question end up like the
philippines paralyzed against their will
by an endless cycle of incompetence and
corruption
one obvious solution is to do as
singapore does pay them so much that
they don't have to resort to bribery
members of its parliament are given a
monthly allowance three times higher
than the median household income
and its prime minister is the world's
highest paid political leader earning
four times as much as the u.s president
the results are compelling no politician
has been charged with corruption in two
decades and the country is tied for
second place on the corruption
perception index
but of course this is easier said than
done
high public salaries are a luxury most
of the world simply can't afford
it's no coincidence that the countries
at the top of the list are also the
world's wealthiest
of the top 10 for example the poorest is
new zealand with a per capita gdp of 41
000
china on the other hand discovered a
much cheaper solution
one invisible to the corruption
perception index which lumps half a
dozen different things together under
this nebulous umbrella term
more interesting than how much
corruption is what kind
yun ng in her book china's gilded age
argues there are actually four distinct
types
when the rich world hears the word
corruption we imagine the one percent of
the one percent presidents prime
ministers and oligarchs colluding in
poorly lit rooms to siphon off public
funds for personal gain
yachts mansions and private jets
that's grand theft
conversely people from lower income
regions may not have to imagine they can
simply remember a cop soliciting bribes
this is known as petty theft
whether small or large theft is bad for
everyone but the thief
when your leader embezzles public funds
to buy rare leopard skin hats you
receive nothing
but there's another dimension exchanges
transactions in which the buyer receives
special treatment
if you need 20 permits to open a
restaurant you almost have to pay what's
called speed money to overcome the red
tape
this is better than mere theft because
at least you get something in return
you're not worse off after paying the
bribe
still you're certainly not celebrating
but then there's something called access
money exchanges that make both parties
much better off
now make no mistake all corruption is
bad
but bad to who when and how
if you are a business the theft kind is
just a loss what economists would call a
tax
access money on the other hand is
actually an investment
suddenly you're able to buy certain
privileges that you previously couldn't
and this kind is precisely what china
has the most of
here's how it works
at the top of each regional government
remember is a powerful elite whose
performance is evaluated based on
objective metrics like economic growth
the problem his or her next promotion
requires the cooperation of hundreds or
thousands of poorly paid subordinates
what motivation does the bureaucrat
making 80 bucks a month have to play
along
so the two reach an agreement help me
climb the ladder and i'll make sure
you're well taken care of
government departments are allowed to
operate almost like independent
businesses keeping some portion of
whatever they collect in fees and taxes
some of this money in turn is used to
shower workers with perks that would
make even a google employee jealous
everything from food to vacations
parties housing electricity gas child
care furniture and equipment
although public wages are set below
market rates formal salaries only
comprise 24 of the average bureaucrats
total compensation
when these unofficial benefits are
included you can see they're actually
doing quite well
bureaucrats may be short on cash but
that doesn't mean you won't spot them on
the golf course or beach sipping
champagne
but don't lose the forest for the trees
the point is not that government workers
are well paid it's that they receive a
kind of unofficial commission
every last cadre no matter how low on
the org chart has a personal stake in
the country's development
does your office need new computers is
your family due for a tropical vacation
chinese bureaucrats can and do extort
businesses for a few quick bucks but the
big money is in attracting businesses
from whom most taxes are generated local
governments ferociously compete to be
tesla ikea and walmart's best friend
one province for instance introduced
leave business alone days during which
inspections and other regulatory
intrusions were banned
another county slogan is quote investors
are gods bureaucrats are humble servants
and those who harm corporate interests
are sinners
the genius of the chinese system is that
it found an innovative way to harness
corruption for the greater good
paradoxically this incredible economic
growth was made possible by millions of
officials using public funds to play
blackjack in macau and buy designer
handbags in paris we think of the
chinese central government as
all-powerful and all-encompassing able
to wield its authority far and wide
but there remain practical and physical
limits to what's possible
eliminating corruption is hard if not
impossible on a budget
so instead china carefully manages which
kind is tolerated as you can clearly see
non-transactional theft has been
systematically targeted while business
friendly favors are left alone
likewise just as bureaucrats are managed
by an imperfect combination of carrot
and stick so too are individual citizens
chinese censorship is highly coercive
technologically advanced and effective
but it's not perfect and surprisingly
nor is it absolute
authoritarian governments like china's
are a giant black box shrouded in doubt
and secrecy but understanding what it
does and doesn't censor is a rare and
revealing reflection of how the
communist party thinks and what it fears
most
this video has been about how china
controls its cadres
this full-length 15-minute nebula
original about how china controls its
people is the very first episode in my
new series explaining how the country
actually works starting by looking
underneath the black bar of censorship
what gets censored and even more
interesting what doesn't and why
the team and i have been working
overtime to bring you an additional
nebula exclusive video for every other
one you see on youtube these are full
length normal polymatter videos not
bonus extended or director's cuts
in other words you can start getting 50
more polymatter for just 12 bucks a year
right now for mother's day by signing up
to the curiosity stream and nebula
bundle
on top of that you'll get access to
dozens of nebula originals and
exclusives not to mention ad-free videos
from your favorite creators
on curiosity stream you'll find great
feature-length documentaries like this
one about a japanese family who rents
fake friends and spouses for social
events
click the link on screen right now to
get both nebula and curiosity stream for
an amazing 15 bucks a year and go watch
the companion video over on nebula